I had no appreciation for just how much
was figured out at a big business so
like I come into this entrepreneurial
world as Mr Fortune 500 I'm I'm thinking
about you know packaging and consumer
research and I come to find out like
they don't have a price list and I'm
like oh okay and I started to have those
realizations of oh like we have payroll
next Thursday and we have to meet that
so the numbers were a lot smaller but it
was the stakes felt a lot higher
all right guys bang bang I've got Dan
here Dan you are one of the very special
people who has worked with 3G uh craft
Hinds and really seen some of the
biggest deals in the history of business
or at least In Our Lifetime talk a
little bit about your experience and
kind of the acquisition and then
obviously the integration and the
scaling of that business uh as it's gone
over the last couple years yeah so I
kind have a traditional business
background you know Consulting private
Equity portfolio company uh got me MBA
from duke and then went to go work for
at the time hindes North America in
their brand Management Group that was
where the brand managers you know they
had full P all responsibility and you
know there was marketing component too
but I that's where I really wanted to
learn how to run a business so I was
there for a year or two and that's when
uh 3G Capital came in in 2013 or 20 yeah
I think it was 2013 um and you know for
those that are aware of the 3G model
it's uh it's pretty disruptive uh to put
it politely so I you know a lot of
people jump ship but I kept my head down
uh and ended up working my way for that
organization pretty quickly and um you
know learned a lot through the 3G model
I didn't see I to ey with all of it but
they were right about a lot of things um
in my opinion so uh you know we did that
whole integration for a couple years um
I led the whole condiments portfolio to
Super Bowl commercials all of that and
then the the next big move was the
integration uh quote unquote with craft
in 2015 so I was part of the team that
did that uh boots on the ground
integrating craft in Hines and craft was
a lot bigger than Hines at the time so
it was uh pretty ambitious uh to to uh
to use a word and uh just to give people
a sense of what that looked like you
know uh my job there was leading the2
billion doll uh then craft Hines
condiments portfolio we own probably
half the condiments aisle all the salad
dressings all the um you know mustard
ketchup barbecue sauce the whole deal um
and there was a team I think of 75 and
then they gave that portfolio to me and
said here's a team of seven good luck so
really really disruptive change um you
know I I didn't really at the time
believe it was going to work it was too
much too soon uh sadly I ended up being
right about that um now obviously that
was this is a decade ago so this is a no
way commentary on Craft H's current
situation um but that's kind of when it
was a lot of short-term incentives
pandering to Wall Street proving to them
the 3G model would work um so long story
short I kind of wasn't having a whole
lot of fun anymore and I was the first
first person to ever kind of walk from
that partnership group uh of craft Hines
and then that's why I wanted to take a
very very different path and do
something more entrepreneurial which is
why I left the the fortune 150 company
now when you think about 3G most people
maybe have heard of uh the organization
but they actually don't know what
they're doing how they do it you you
kind of went through this and you know
got a front row seat describe a little
bit about the 3G model and why you
describe it as disruptive yeah so it's
it's aggressive
cost cutting um I'm oversimplifying a
bit but they'll go after some you know
historically you know big cpg companies
can be a little bloated I think they are
right about that from an objective
business standpoint um so there's
aggressive cost cutting uh sometimes on
the Personnel side very very uh
aggressive renegotiation of all vendor
relationships supplier relationships um
you know which can be tough if you have
a trusted supplier of 30 years they do
not care it's all about price wipe this
slate clean and a lot of pretty
aggressive tactics there um and you know
they also have a a pretty well
publicized zerob based budgeting uh
policy which basically means you don't
budget off of last year you budget off
of zero it's part of the planning
process and then every penny that you
want to be part of your budget you have
to fight for so it doesn't matter that
you spent $10 million on TV supporting
Hines catchup last year your number for
next year is zero and with everything in
the business so um that's all the bigger
stuff and you know they set that culture
through very lean travel even Executives
or flying coach and you know renting
crappy cars and that type of thing so
it's just very very aggressive cost
control um and you know they were able
to drive massive movement in margin in a
very short time period as a result the
the problem was it's pretty disruptive
culturally because a lot of people quit
um you know they like to to kind of bet
on me at the time I was a lot younger
where you know they could give me the
big fancy job and pay me probably a
fraction of what the old the old person
met made and that in that role um so
that's why you see I think the the the
global CFO was 28 years old or something
so they'll do some pretty unprecedented
things uh in their organization so uh
but to their credit they are willing to
invest where it matters I mean we put a
lot of quality back into products I
think uh the the current model of food
and big food companies there's a lot of
short-term incentives it becomes very
easy to cost cut and take quality out um
and you don't really pay the price for
that until the years in the out years so
I I think they do some things right it's
it's a little more aggressive than most
it's certainly not for everyone um in
what most people don't realize that the
hin experiment with 3G was actually
working um it was Private at the time
and then once they it was a little too
much too soon with with craft in my
opinion when you talk about these cost
cutting you mentioned uh obviously ly
there's Personnel Cuts there's uh vendor
renegotiations are there any other kind
of extreme things that you saw just to
give people a sense of like how
aggressive this is yeah I mean basically
you go anywhere on the p&l uh there was
a whole department called Revenue
management which any of you consumer
products people out there you know trade
spend it's promotional spend in the
grocery store and it's a huge line item
in cpg pnls where you know Walmart wants
you to spend x amount in sales for hind
ketchup for the big seasons for instance
um and all the big grocery stores have
it and it's it's a little bit of
relationship spend and they would come
in and aggressively cut those because
the ROI in those dollars wasn't always
super high in the spend got a little bit
bloated a little inefficient you know
every year you add another sale and you
look up after a decade and say whoa like
this line in the p&l has gotten out of
control so to undo that like to get off
the drug or promotion can be difficult
um so you know you're sitting at the
table with a Walmart or a Kroger
representing Hines catch and it's a bit
little bit of chicken right and you're
you're making pretty aggressive say hey
Kroger we're pulling a ton of money out
of this and they don't like it but you
know as a brand like H's ketchup me you
can sometimes get away with it so they
weren't afraid of anybody or anything
and you know you have that mentality
kind of the bowl in the china shop and
you can kind of get away with it
sometimes and you know that maybe you'll
take some licks along the way but they
that was kind of the strategy now when
you leave um you've got this great
experience uh you've obviously seen kind
of inside the belly of the Beast of a
fortune 150 company uh you could pretty
much do almost anything you wanted to do
in the business world coming with the
background that you had and the
experience that you had why do you go to
milkshake Factory and what was so
enticing about going and working on this
yeah I actually at the time was a a
small chocolate business called Edward
Mark Brands and uh I what I know I
didn't want to do is you know I had
peers that would jump ship and go work
for PNG or General Mills and again great
companies it's not against them but but
it's still kind of the same thing like I
knew I wanted to do something radically
different um I always thought that
entrepreneurship could be a decent fit
because I didn't love the Optics and the
politics and the pandering to Wall
Street and all that stuff I just wanted
to grow a business um for the long term
so that's why I got a little bit uh yeah
it's kind of again stopped having fun
but that's when I met a family called
the Edwards family they're fourth
generation chocolateers the fourth
generation actually had very prominent
careers in the White House in the George
W Bush Administration so they were
flying around Air Force One and all the
big events of History 9911 Ground Zero
and Katrina I mean they have amazing
stories they gave that up to come back
to the family chocolate business which
at the time you know this was not some
big you know come back and and and get
on the family business gravy train I
mean the business maybe had a couple
hundred grand in sales like I truly
don't even know how they paid themselves
um so they left the White House in Air
Force One and came back to this tiny
little chocolate factory in Suburban
Pittsburgh um you know their conference
room table was a moving box flipped
upside down so just like real
entrepreneurial grit story uh and to
their credit they they grew that
business and they actually they won the
chocolate contract in the Pentagon so
they opened up a chocolate shop inside
the Pentagon it was the the world's most
secure chocolate shop and then that
enabled them to get some volume and then
they got some nice press in the
Washington posts that got the attention
of the Costco buyer and then they got in
front of Costco and co-created this item
called Snappers and you know we can talk
about Costco I think Costco is a
brilliant business is a wildly
overlooked strategy in most of cpg
because people don't understand it um
but the beauty about being an
entrepreneur in Costco is it's cash flow
positive in day one uh it can really
really give you a massive head start so
they got into Costco and you know they
went from you know a bunch of little old
ladies hand making chocolates on trays
selling cases here and there to selling
you know four tractor trailer loads to
Costco so again awesome entrepreneurial
story of hand welding chocolate lines
and production and all of that to make
it happen and they got into the
Northeast the product sold and then
there's eight regions of Costco and then
it started kind of spreading like
wildfire so they were on kind of the
early stages of this Title Wave of
growth and that's when I met them and we
got to talking and I was like huh this
is a really good product you know fun
brand like let's let's give it a go and
then I was fortunate that I could bring
you know probably I think I brought
eight people with me from Craft hindes
of the best of the best so we had in my
opinion kind of a world class cpg team
on this tiny little chocolate brand um
but once I got into it like I had no
appreciation for just how much was
figured out at a big business so like I
come into this entrepreneurial world as
Mr Fortune 500 I'm I'm thinking about
you know packaging and consumer research
and I come to find out like they don't
have a price list and I'm like oh okay
and I started to have those realiz
ations of oh like we have payroll next
Thursday and we have to meet that so the
numbers were a lot smaller but it was
the stakes felt a lot higher if that
made sense so um we ended up doing a
whole bunch of work there uh we grew
that business from essentially nothing
to about 50 million in Revenue uh over
over the course of about six years you
know we're in the Inc 5,000 fastest
growing companies in America for six
straight years so uh most of that was on
the back of Costco through
diversification via Brands and products
um we did some other stuff in retail as
well and then uh milkshake Factory was
actually a bit of an afterthought which
we can get into next but the chocolate
business was actually how I made my LEAP
from Craft Hines into this kind of crazy
entrepreneurial World talk about the
transition from what I'll call literally
small business and you know kind of
little ladies making chocolate on trays
as you described it to uh kind of hey we
should probably have some sort of
production line and we should actually
have a price list and we should kind of
professionalize the business it sounds
like you all were pretty
um you know uh integral as you brought
this team to come and do that is it
something where you guys showed up and
you were like hey here's all the things
we got to do or did they actually
understand hey we got to make a lot of
changes here but we don't necessarily
have the time or the expertise to go do
it and so let's go find people who can
come and do these things this episode is
brought to you by cal.com what do I have
in common with Chad Hurley from YouTube
Toby from Shopify and Alexis from 776
and the co-founder of Reddit we all use
cal.com instead of cly and we are all
early investors as well
cal.com is leading the charge of
scheduling Platforms in the open-source
sphere offering you the chance to
harness the efficiency previously
reserved for leag corporations and Tech
gurus if you like to have your calendar
organized and be able to have an
efficient exchange when scheduling but
you love all of the benefits of
open-source technology then cal.com is
for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your time yeah I think
they were smart enough to know what they
didn't know now again they're
chocolateers they can do everything
about the product and whatever else but
you know they're in a Costco meeting and
saying like you know they're Googling
what's a case what's a pallet like they
mean what's packaging they they know
anything um so that's when when they met
me you know I'm kind of the I call the
cpg fundamentals guy so anyone in cpg
there's a very structured Playbook you
have to have in terms of of pricing and
promotion and strategy and margin and
distribution and you know on and on and
on it goes right and like if you don't
execute that well you are going to
really struggle like that's just the
reality now doing that stuff doesn't
guarantee your success so you know I
came in in the first I think 20 days we
changed the packaging because we knew
the functional communication wasn't
there right because and then we you know
with the the product quality with shelf
life wasn't there because they were hot
depositing caramel on pretzels there's a
whole I won't bore you with all the
chemistry but if you hot deposit caramel
on pretzels the the moist caramel wants
to find equilibrium with a dry pretzel
you end up with hard caramel and a soggy
pretzel and when the bag sits on the
Shelf of Target for potentially eight
months you end up with a really bad
product so you know we reformulated the
product I think it was 27 times um but
just basic stuff around cpg fundamentals
packaging product shelf life margin Etc
and that's when you know I and others
came in um the Edwards family said yeah
that's why we brought you on like tell
us tell us what we need to do and then
uh Chris the oldest brother and he's a
brilliant uh relationship Builder so
he's very very successful in that Costco
room where he can walk into a room with
Costco and co-create and and sell a
whole bunch of volume um I always joke
that at craft hindes I used to get my
face kicked in by Costco and I could
never sell in anything and they were
super tough and then I walk into my
first Costco meeting with Chris and he
gets a hug from the buyer and I'm like a
hug like what is this so um it goes to
show you know you kind of there's lots
of different paths to uh to success now
what's interesting about that is craft H
is this massive company you think you
would show up there roll out the red
carpet they'd beg you guys to put your
product in the store uh they'd be you
know throwing money out the window as
you leave like it it would just be this
amazing relationship the little choler
though you they're getting the hug what
is the difference between people and
maybe the brands with somebody like a
Costco yeah well Costco is all about the
member and a little bit about the
treasure hunt and and they don't really
care about the brand they care about the
product because they know the member
doesn't really care about Brands so you
know the fact that you know I was
representing you know the the Hines
brands or whatever they were like okay
cool how good's the how good's the
product what's the price is this the
best price and then it's tough right
because if Costco I'm Gonna Know hindes
ketchup for example Costco wants some
crazy price and then Walmart sees it
then they're mad at me now all of a
sudden they got a much bigger issue on
my hands right whereas the small
Chocolat here you're not in Walmart
you're like yeah let's co-create oh you
want a little more chocolate a little
more caramel let's change the bag size
let's change the price let's change the
name of the product let's change the
picture on the bag and if you do it
right you you know we were very
successful in almost co-creating with
these buyers so many people go into
Costco and they try to like hey here's
my product like you got to buy it and
for us it was like hey here's some ideas
we have and we have a whole table full
of samples and we just co-create real
time in the meeting if you can do that
right then the buyer is emotionally
invested in that product because they
created it with you and that's a big
deal if you actually understand how
Costco Works uh in in terms of some of
the politics and the buying Network so
it was was it's not you know we could go
in with that strategy with Walmart hey
we're the little chocolate here and they
would say we don't care you're not
hershy or Mars and you know we actually
had that experience where they put us in
the bottom corner of the Shelf you know
we didn't perform because we never
really had a chance so that's why for a
lot of uh younger entrepreneurial brands
in cpg and I see them and I you know I
love all these Founders that come up
with these amazing Brands but when they
go after small fragmented Regional
grocery distribution or even a little
bit of Whole Foods like it's a really
tough way to scale because the economics
just aren't there like you can't I can
almost promise you you're not making any
money because the volume isn't there and
then they Hammer you on price and
promotion whereas Costco we built the
entire company a a cash flow positive
from day one because Costco pays in 10
days and our Coman we would pay in 30
it's a brilliant thing right and you and
you're guarant you're shipping tractor
trailer loads of volume all over the
country so uh again Costco's I could
talk all day about Costco I'm a Costco
loyalist till I die I think their their
business model is is just brilliant and
I think they execute it uh better than
anybody in my opinion so we have the
Edwards family they've got the chocolate
business they're in the Pentagon they're
in Costco everything's going amazing got
$50 million in Revenue uh and my
understanding is is that milkshake
Factory basically was created as a
solution to try to entice people to come
in during the summer because I'm
assuming that chocolate and heat don't
do so well together um explain a little
bit the story of the milkshake Factory
it almost seems like it was like a sub
brand that now is scaling nationally as
well yeah so it was funny that you know
I don't want to say it was an
afterthought of the time but as you can
imagine during that 0 to 50 million
growth in the Chocolate Company we were
we were pretty busy and pretty focused
and the Edwards family's mom so you know
third generation she had a little old
chocolate shop on one of the streets in
Pittsburgh you know every little town
has one it's it's you know there's a
million little skews of tiny little
chocolates and if it's not valentine 's
day Easter or holidays it's kind of a
tough business to be in right it's it's
just it's a hard way to make a living so
um Dana the founder of the milkshake
Factory one of her College projects was
like man we don't sell anything in the
summer I mean no one's going in to buy
salted caramels in July so she's like
why don't we start scooping milkshakes
and you know they're fourth generation
chocolateers so of course the recipe and
the shakes are unreal right they're
standard of quality just as impossibly
high so they just started scooping
shakes out of mom's chocolate shop and
then of course people love them because
they were awesome and then they realized
wait a minute this shake business is
actually way better than the chocolate
business so um the the business used to
be called chocolate celebrations and
then they rebranded it to milkshake
Factory um but still the heart of the
milkshake Factory is still chocolate so
um you know it used to be all chocolate
and no shakes now it's about 80% shakes
20% chocolate um but it still it was
just one little retail shop and it was a
milkshake Factory and it it was fine um
but it was it was just kind of off to
the side we didn't really pay much
attention to it but the big inflection
point for milkshake Factory was in 2016
uh PNC Bank was building their Global
headquarters in downtown Pittsburgh you
know gorgeous new building you know lead
certified greenest building in the world
whatever whatever uh and they just
didn't want another Starbucks in their
Lobby so they came to us and said hey
you put a milkshake Factory down here
and we were like you know this is right
in the thick of our chocolate stuff
we're like yeah we we'd love to but we
we just can't we just can't we can't and
we said no I don't know probably 10
times eventually they came with an offer
we couldn't refuse so we kind of
reluctantly put a milkshake Factory in
there and then we decided hey when we're
doing it we might as well do it right so
we rebranded um anyone on video the zoom
background behind me is that store with
all all new architecture and much more
thoughtful branding and design spent way
too much money building it out to be
clear um but once we opened those doors
it was a huge success I mean just
runaway success and that's when we
realized huh like maybe we're on to
something with this milkshake Factory
and that's when we opened six more
stores over the next 18 months around
Pittsburgh Urban Suburban College um Etc
and that's when you know I've done a lot
with different brands in my career and
there's something about the milkshake
Factory that I can't quite articulate um
but people love it they just love
talking about it they love coming to it
it's a little bit of nostalgia you know
no one's really planted their flags of
doing really high quality milkshakes
which we can get into um then we got hit
with co uh got through that that was
tough obviously but it made us better um
have since opened a couple more stores
so we had 10 stores around Pittsburgh to
really validate the model and then you
know within the last year is when we've
kind of got into franchising which which
we can get into so milkshake Factory
really started as this kind of
afterthought and then it kind of turned
into this side project and then it it
wasn't until a couple years after that
when we realized hey wait a minute we
might be on to something and once we
exited the chocolate business uh for for
us and me personally we wanted we've
always really believed in the brand so
we wanted to see you know see what we
could do with it and that's kind of what
we're doing right now so I want to just
do rapid fire a bunch of questions about
the actual business today before we get
into the franchise opportunities that um
that you guys are doing uh so first you
said 10 stores all within uh the
Pittsburgh area what is the distance
between maybe the two farthest from each
other like how many can you pack in from
a density standpoint to a city yeah it
really depends and Pittsburgh is a weird
Market where people don't go across
Bridges and there's tunnels and little
pockets of neighborhoods so um you know
it's about a store per 75 to 100
thousand of population you know give or
take uh it's not quite that simple we
have some stores that are actually less
than a mile apart but they're through a
tunnel and over a river so you know kind
of doesn't really count um but if you go
all the way to the northernmost store to
the southern most they're probably 25
miles apart give or take um so you know
Pittsburgh's I think the you know the
40th biggest Metro in the country or
something like that so I think 10 stores
we could probably opportunistically
maybe put one or two more in but that's
about the stealing for milkshake Factory
and if you think about bigger metros
like you know Dallas Fort Worth or
Atlanta uh obviously the the potential
is a lot more than than 10 or 12 yeah
that makes sense what is the average
revenue on a per store basis and then
what does profit on an annual basis look
like yeah so uh average revenue is
between 8 and 850 um we've got a couple
stores that'll do that'll do seven
figures um U but yeah on average it'll
be between 800 and 850 and then you know
average profit and this is speak from
the franchise side where we're kind of
baking a royalty rate um you know we
like to see around 20% um you know we've
got some corporate stores that'll do in
in the high 20s pushing 30 got it when
you think about the actual products
themselves is this a type of store where
like one milkshake vanilla or chocolate
or you know one thing is 70 80% of all
milkshake shes or is there a pretty
distributed um you know kind of sales um
uh kind of interest if you will yeah
it's very distributed we've been super
intentional like way back at Mom's
chocolate shop it was 55 five shakes
line priced at 450 so we've done a lot
of work I'm a firm firm believer in a
premium brand so we've done a lot of
work uh to premiumize the brand uh and
we kind of have a good better best menu
strategy we have about 20 shakes um
we've got some you know so you know the
good model would be the standard
chocolate vanilla strawberry that's
about 133% of Revenue then we have kind
of a standard bucket of shakes it's you
know it's peanut butter brownie it's
mint cookies and cream stuff like that
and then we have a we just introduced
kind of a more premium tier of shakes um
for the less price conscious consumer
then we also have Sundays and we also
have a dairy free menu and then we also
have the chocolate so the the highest
Shake on our uh menu will do between
seven and 8% of total revenue so it's
it's pretty well it's it's we call it
the illusion of complexity it's this big
beautiful menu but operationally it's
actually super simple to execute but if
you come in um usually it's it's a
little bit of a paradox of choice
situation where consumers have a hard
time picking what they want and then
that usually keeps them coming back the
brand that you mentioning it earlier
like milkshake Factory for some reason
that name just sounds awesome and has
this like brand promise of like I'm
going to the the pros right um the
stores obviously when you walk in uh I
recently interviewed Ron Shake who's
founder of Panera has been the chairman
of Cava and he talks a lot about the
experience like not only does the brand
have to kind of resonate but also when
you walk in it's got to feel like you're
getting that brand promise before you
ever even taste the product how much
does it cost to build out one of these
stores yeah so uh in our uh franchise
Disclosure document the range is about
490 up to about you know 6 650 is so
split the difference call it 550 is
that's with a franchise fee so you know
it depends a lot on area and square
footage and um buildout and what you
negotiate with your lease etc etc but
ballpark um just a rice round number
call it you know
5550 and then what about uh people who
come get a milkshake eat in the actual
location versus they taking it to go
like how do you think about that stuff
and then also is there a delivery
component to this where you start to try
to figure out okay how do we actually
bring the milkshakes to people where
they are versus have them come to the
store yeah so we offer some seating most
of our stores will have anywhere from
kind of eight to 20 seats so there's
some seats but uh you know we're not a
coffee shop you're not bringing your
laptop and hanging out all day and doing
work uh and then basically we've
realized that some of our small the
store we just open is only 1300 square
feet and you see a lot of this in qsr
and Retail where they realize you
actually can drive pretty comparable
revenues off of a more efficient layouts
and more efficient layouts mean you know
cheaper to get open and cheaper rent
because rent is based on dollars per per
square qu where you know our first store
is over 2,000 ft and we have this really
nice little dining area but you're
looking and you're like man that's an
extra 500 square feet that we probably
don't really need like I personally
would bet we could drive 90% of Revenue
without that because milkshakes are a
very portable format it's not an ice
cream cone people are willing to take
you know the kid can carry the shakes
out so we try to offer some seating for
people that want to hang out for maybe
10 15 minutes as a group or it's the
little league baseball team or whatever
but it's not a linger and and sit down
down type of model and you know we do
well when there's places to go outside
the store because then it's a win for
the consumer they can go sit on the
bench or the whatever or the table and
then we don't have to pay for it so
that's kind of how we think about the
store but definitely airing on the
smaller side uh really drives Capital
efficiency um which is a which is a huge
deal and then let's talk sorry go ahead
I was gonna say let's talk about the
unit economics of a single milkshake
itself um you know you pick one but what
does it look like if you're selling it
for you know X dollar what does the cost
look like and then kind of if you could
break down some of that cost how much of
it is like the actual uh chocolate you
know ice cream or or any other
ingredients they going into it today's
episode is brought to you by trust and
will I've gone through a number of
different changes in my life over the
last few years I got married I had a kid
and I had to start thinking about how
could I ensure that my wife and my child
would be okay if anything ever happened
to me that's where trust wills and
estate planning come into play now most
people what they do is they get
introduced to a friend an uncle or
someone in their local community it
tends to be someone who's really
expensive a lawyer an accountant or
somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one-size
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five-star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trustand will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all your estate planning
documents so go to trustand will.com
Pomp and make sure you get an estate
plan in place whether it's for you or
one of your loved ones having a trust
Endor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trust and will.com slomp
yeah so it really varies but I mean on
average you know we we like the the
shakes to be in the kind of like the
75ish margin range um now the big
component that we make all of our ice
cream in stores so the ice cream in the
subsequent Dairy that goes into that ice
cream that we make in stores is the
biggest cost component uh and then you
know we make our all of our own
proprietary syrups with real vanilla so
you know we're not skimping on cost for
for our inclusion it's all you know it's
real strawberry purees I mean you can
look at our vanilla syrup that we use
and it's jet black because there's
vanilla be in it you know you can go to
Starbucks and look at their vanilla
syrup and it's clear right so like those
little things uh and you again our
Founders as fourth generation
chocolateers they say like I don't care
how big we get and it's always tempting
right just to cut a couple corners here
and there um you know we just simply
refuse to do it because if we're the
milkshake Factory and you don't have the
best shake you ever had you know what
what what are we really doing right
that's the that's the flag that we have
planted so you know we try to drive
pretty good margin through the business
um you know we're tweaking the business
a little bit we're making a lot of
chocolate in store uh which basically
means you're using Free Labor it's labor
that's already on the clock that you're
paying for during downtime you know it's
Tuesday at 2m you know we're not that
busy and you're paying a couple people
to be there they can make some chocolate
if someone walks through the door of
course you know making a shake um so
little changes like that it's really
about optimizing a hyper efficient labor
model is just critical in this business
and that's when Co really revolutionized
that for us in terms of running you know
how lean we can be and and our cost base
is actually uh pretty pretty fixed so
when you drive the seven figures of
Revenue um obviously there's a lot of
profitability there now what's
interesting to me is let's take just the
market of Pittsburgh right you guys have
10 stores uh within called 25 mile
radius you know give or take with many
of them even closer than that um it's
very different than if you had T stores
across the country right and so uh we
have seen some stores um specifically in
cpg say you know what we're going to do
is actually we're going to have one
central location where in your guys case
you're going to make the ice cream the
chocolate whatever uh we're going to go
and we're going to Warehouse all of the
um you know various uh containers and
things that we need whatever and then
we're just going to use it almost as
like a distribution point to these 10
stores how much of that in kind of
logistics efficiency on a you know local
scale are you guys really pursuing
versus no we need to have this model be
able to be Standalone and and each store
needs to be able to do every single one
of these things as we scale AC the
country yeah so we have not done kind of
the Hub and spoke from a from a
distribution model you know we we when I
say we make our ice cream in the stores
meaning the individual stores we're not
making it at an off-site location and
shipping it to the stores and we're
trying to set up obviously now as we're
going towards franchising it's a very
different animal when you think about
National supply chain especially you
know we're not growing regionally you
know we're selling units in Utah in
Texas in Florida in North Carolina and
Connecticut Etc so that presents some
challenges so it's really all about
finding that right distribution Network
nwor um and there's a whole network of
Distributors out there for both Dairy
and all of the other Goods that we have
um so that's that's kind of the that was
been the challenge of the last six
months is taking our supply chain from
Regional you know we got kind of nine
little you know Mom and popish type uh
you know vendors in in in network where
you know that that's not scalable
nationally so there is a bit of a weird
chicken and egg where you know you're
kind of you need the volume to work with
the big guys but sometimes it's hard to
get the volume unless you're with the
big guys so there's a bit of a chicken
and egg there so we're working through
that um in terms of what that National
supply chain looks like but you think
you see food and beverage Brands all the
time um you know it's a challenge
getting product where it needs to be uh
reliably and at the right price so we're
spending a ton of time on that right now
let's talk about franchise so obviously
you've got 10 corporate stores uh you're
doing pretty well right business is
growing at some point you guys decided
let's go do the franchise model um what
are the pros and cons of the decision
and and what pushed you guys ultimately
to decide to do it versus refraining
yeah so you know coming out of coid we
had opened two more stores we were
sitting at 10 stores in Pittsburgh so
really the decision was three-fold you
know choice a is Run a 10 store business
in Pittsburgh and there's nothing wrong
with that that's a perfectly nice
business to run uh option b would be
expand via corporate development model
and then option C would be franchise and
you know we all kind of sat around the
table and said like man we really really
believe in this brand I think Pittsburgh
is kind of a c minus milkshake Market um
you talk about why but the fact that
we're as successful as we are in
Pittsburgh I think has a shows that
there's a lot of potential for this
brand uh in my opinion and so they said
all right well we're not standing Pat is
not an option so how do we grow right
what's the strategy look like and if you
actually get into the economics of a
corporate development model now if you
want to do it for you know look at what
Culver has done over the course of many
decades kind of methodical systematic
growth and again hats off to them
they've done it brilliantly um but you
know they've done it over the course of
a generation and and kind of slow until
you build that up uh and then and then
they've obviously picked it up but in
ter in terms of just either raising
money or spending our own money it is
very very Capital intensive to grow a
qsr brand on your own to meaningful
scale you know we could go open up
another 10 stores but let's say we
wanted to open up you know 40 more
stores you know rough math you need at
least $20 million likely more and you're
like o like like that's in from a
valuation standpoint 10 stores in
Pittsburgh I mean the whole company's
not even worth that you know I mean it
doesn't work right so that's kind of
when we realized you know we didn't set
out to franchise at all and I I honestly
was a little dismissive of franchising
I'm embarrassed to admit um but then
once we started learning about it we
realized we had the perfect brand for it
in terms of super simple operations
super scalable uh you no one's doing
what we're doing a proven concept with
10 stores you know check check check so
we're kind of the the FNB solution for
people that don't want to do FNB um and
then we were smart enough to know you
know we're business people but we're not
franchise people so I spent most of last
year talking to every franchise
development company in the country right
there's kind of these um these houses
that will help you franchise your
business because there's a lot of I
equate it to walking through a field of
landmines uh it's really easy to step on
one and if you step on one it can be
game over so we wanted help kind of
walking through that field and um long
story short ended up partnering with a a
company called franworth and you know in
my opinion they're the they're the best
of the best they get 400 deals across
their desk every year um they'll do one
or two and then our big moment of
validation and these guys all are big-
time you know ex franchise CEOs um
they've scaled big franchise brands from
nothing to 500 um Etc you know Drew
Breeze the Hall of Fame quarterback as
part of that group so it's when they all
came to Pittsburgh and said wow like
this operation is incredible and this
product is incredible that was our
moment of validation because we had our
10 little stores I don't know like we
like it does anybody else and then when
the franworth folks came and were really
blown away that's when it was like okay
I think you know we're going to give
this a go and then we formed our
franchising entity at the beginning of
uh this calendar year what's up with
Drew Brees in h franchises I think he's
also involved in uh everb which is like
franchise con involved in a lot sliders
Walk-Ons beastro everb and um you know
he's such a great guy I I spend a little
time with him and he's so humble where
you meet him and and he's like hey I'm
Drew I'm like yeah I know um so just
like he's just like you he just so
humble uh and just so he's so meticulous
and thoughtful you can kind of see why
he was so successful on the on on the
field and you'd think that you know
you're going into athletes all the time
of varying levels of sophistication I
think there's a lot happening in that
space which I love um but Drew was just
so plugged in asking great questions
about the business and talking about his
businesses so you know he's not some
sports figurehead who's just cutting
checks I mean he is in it and I give him
a lot of credit he is he is a really
really sharp guy but he's also like one
of the nicest guys you'd ever meet so um
yeah it's cool just to kind of have
access to him and yeah he actually even
yesterday was you know I think he
tweeted about us of oh I'm so excited
about milkshake Factory and he wants to
open one in San Diego or whatever so um
so yeah it's kind of fun just to you
know H have him on the team that's
awesome um let's talk about the
franchisees how do you evaluate who the
right franchise is uh obviously they're
going to operate your business they're
going to be their local representative
they're going to ensure you know kind of
brand and like all these components are
really important but also they're going
to be part of generating revenue for you
and so they've got to have the business
sense as well but like how do you go
through that evaluation process andbody
decide on people yeah huge deal it's a
huge deal because you're effectively
getting married to these people right
where like they're you're going to be
business partners for a decade or two
and if they fail especially the early
ones um you know we're kind of sunk the
model has to validate and by validate I
mean franchises have to get open and
they have to say nice things about us
and then then we go award more units and
that's how the snowball grow so if our
first franchises aren't successful um
you know our growth trajectory looks
very very different so that is why this
conversation is so important so we have
a whole franchise sales organization
that goes through I think it's a 10-step
process highly vetted you know walking
through all of the the different
components of the business um so they
need to deeply understand the business
they obviously need to be vetted
financially to make sure they have
Capital um because as as everyone knows
if you're out of capital that's a that's
that's that's a problem so they go
through that very rigorous process and
then our final step is what we call
Discovery day where all people who make
it through that whole process will come
to Pittsburgh for a 24hour period meet
the team spend time in stores very
immersive it's a half day of
presentations the goal is that they
would leave that with all of their
questions answered and you know they're
vetting us of course but we're also
vetting them so that's kind of our
two-way kind of matchmaking thing um and
you know we've said you know we'll
probably end this year with around 50 to
60 units of rewarded and if we said yes
to everybody that you know was
financially qualified and wanted to
invest that number would have been about
2x higher right and those are tough
conversations to have because people
want to buy in they're ready and they
say yes I want to do x amount of units
in X market and we have to say you know
I'm sorry I don't think you're a great
fit a big thing we look for is this is a
people business right and if you can't
build culture and lead a team and hire a
good team and be out in your community
this is not the business for you right
so I think some people fall into the
trap of thinking oh I'm going to start a
business and it's going to be mailbox
money um so I try to sniff that out and
I try to be very transparent upfront
like if you think this is mailbox money
I'll look you right in the eyes and say
it's not and it's not anything close and
if a brand does tell you that I would be
very very leery because usually that
doesn't exist how many of these people
have previous franchisee experience
they've been doing whether it's one D's
Chick-fil-A you know or maybe even non
you know food and beverage type Concepts
versus those that this is the first
franchisee that uh situation they're
going to enter into I would say about
half so you meet people with you know
all varying levels you know I talk to
people that are oh I have 40 Pizza Huts
and you know big big scale right all the
way to you know we just approved a group
uh in their 20s that is just hungry and
they're fed up with their corporate gig
and they're ready to run through a wall
to make this happen and I love people
like that I bet on those guys any day
they're going to open one unit so
there's kind of a whole Spectrum um but
you see people that have been in the
franchising game a while you know it's
it's it's not rocket science you pick
the right brand
you get open and it doesn't have to be
food and Home Services um Beauty Fitness
whatever and then roll profits into
growth and do that for a decade or two
and that's how you look up and you have
40 Pizza Huts so there's people that are
looking to you know diversify their
franchise portfolio um and and there's
some pretty Heavy Hitters that'll have
kind of centralized resources that'll
manage a franchise portfolio across
maybe four or five Brands and they say
oh you know M factory is kind of cool
you know we'd love to do it and we can
kind of plug it into our infrastructure
uh and it can be pretty profitable so
it's a wide range um but yeah I'd say
about half those big players what are
they doing in the centralized Services
is it just like management
centralization p&l centralization or or
something else basically the big thing
would be think of all the back back
office stuff so usually there's some
like it infrastructure system stuff a
big thing is hiring right if you can
imagine for business like ours just it
you know there's a lot of churn and it's
summer workers and management turnover
and it's kind of that game that you're
in so having a a a scalable and
efficient hiring operation is huge and
then if you think about centralized book
bookkeeping and accounting um in in HR
which obviously is related to hiring so
so kind of that type of stuff where if
you're just a random franchisee with a
store or two you're probably just doing
it all yourself um but if you have a
network of 50 or 100 locations obviously
you can afford to uh professionalize
your operation a little bit and and some
of the the the the numbers that those
those folks do are are pretty impressive
I've had the Great great Fortune of
interviewing a ton of people who have
started uh some of these franchisees
businesses uh everyone from uh you know
Dunkin' Donuts all the way on down and
one of the things that always fascinates
me is there's almost two different uh
ways to kind of have oversight there's
like the qualitative and the
quantitative uh obviously quantitative
like you're getting the p&l you you know
are they getting foot traffic are they
not are they getting profit are they not
but in terms of the qualitative how do
you do you guys just show up in the
store and like is it clean you know are
the people nice like like how do you
kind of quality check if you will yeah I
mean honestly like what all starts with
the numbers right that's the source of
Truth and usually if you're driving good
numbers then something's working but uh
I think there's a couple sources of
Truth where for us it's it's about again
we tell people all the time we'll teach
you how to make shakes we'll teach you
how to open your store you need to run a
good culture and that mean that
translates into friendly customer
service and keep your store clean like
our store has no commercial you know
kitchen equipment there's no friers
there's no grease traps there's no gross
kitchens like our store is spotless and
you know the bathroom is spotless right
so literally good customer service in a
clean store I know it sounds so simple
but that'll get you pretty far in this
business so I think a lot of that will
manifest itself into reviews so reviews
especially when the sample size gets a
little larger even across our 10 stores
like without looking I haven't looked at
the reviews in probably a couple months
I could probably rank our stores bu
reviews uh in order and I'd probably get
it right right because you know you
always have someone that'll you know
someone will Hammer you for a onear
review because of whatever and that's
inevitable but if you can get the sample
size of hundreds or even better
thousands of reviews um that means
you're doing something right so some of
our stores will have you know 2,000 4.8
star reviews and you're like okay that
that's a big deal now again sadly
there's some games you can play in the
review world with Bots and stuff so we
don't we don't do that stuff um so that
playing field is a little bit tainted
but I do think if you look at reviews
you can kind of see okay why is this
store 4.3 instead of 4.8 and why are
people complaining about you know
service or cleanliness or whatever um
and then if you kind of have that the
more qualitative side and then if you
layer on the quanitative side obviously
there's a there's usually a story to be
told there as well that makes sense um
my last two questions for you around
economics of this kind of franchise
model how much does it cost in terms of
the franchisee putting in to get started
and then what does it look like if let's
say the store does a million dollars in
Revenue you have cost you have kind of
the franchise fee you have all this
stuff like what does that look like for
the as well yeah so the number I
mentioned earlier that 550 number that
includes our $60,000 franchise fee now
again that $60,000 is for one store if
you go all the way up to 10 you get the
volume discount and it works out to 35k
so think about a sliding scale from 60
to 35k per store depending on how many
you buy so that's upfront kind of do at
closing um and then you know that's kind
of I view it as one bucket of
pre-opening costs so that 550 number I
mentioned that counts that franchise fee
of that's how much it cost to sign your
fa to getting open on average of course
it's there's decent variables on either
side um and then ideally you know I I
love for cash on cash return to be
around three years is a decent Benchmark
for this industry um now obviously if
you can use leverage and things like
that you can juice your own returns
quite a bit better than that um but you
know I think if you're doing a million
dollar store you know your profitability
should be in the you know ideally you
know 20 to 25 or even higher range and
that includes a 6% royalty and 2% brand
fund but again that's just our
experience with the corporate stores I
have to be careful not to project what
the franchisee can make because that's
an earnings claim so I try to be super
transparent in our FDD um our item 19
which is where we disclose all of our
data we have all store pnls everything
so you can kind of see see what we're
doing in there and get a pretty good
sense for the the business and the p&l
yeah that makes a ton of sense Dan this
is fascinating to me and I I appreciate
you kind of explaining it so well to uh
to folks um I'm left I guess just with
actually one last question which is just
like you worked at the big company now
you worked at the small company that's
quickly becoming a big company which
one's more fun uh I think we all know
the answer to that it's the small
company come on yeah I again all love to
the big company folks I've got a lot of
friends at big companies if I have it my
way I will never go back to a big
company I you know I I read about
quarterly earnings and I'm like what are
we doing like I I just am out on the
whole thing I love just getting a small
group together with inlined incentives
I'm such a big believer in people right
so I spent almost all my time just
trying to get the right people to the
table that's our team that's our
partners it's franworth um it's our
agency partners and obviously it's our
franchisees and you know I'm really
proud of what we've done this year and
we such a great group of people that I
like I just genuinely like and genuinely
want to hang out with and uh you know we
don't have to talk about q1 earnings um
which is which is pretty awesome I love
it where where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find out
more about milkshake Factory yeah so I'm
trying to be a little more active on
Twitter I've been enjoying that so I'm
Dan Reese
re21 so trying to engage with folks
there we've been having fun with that
and then we're at milkshake factory.com
and we have a whole franchise page so
yeah anyone interested in in milkshake
Factory or even not just franchising in
general please reach out to me on
Twitter um via DM Happy to chat awesome
Dan thanks so much for that do it again
in the future all right I appreciate it